l' angoisse en belgique après la
nouvelle action sauvage d'une bande de
gangsters fiche on est au début des
années 80 la province du brabant en
belgique est frappé par une série de
braquages meurtriers
le bilan est lourd plusieurs morts dont
des enfants
trois hommes masqués peut être quatre
fautes irruption sur le parking et tire
dans la foule
cette mort gratuitement une famille
décimée de filles est de 14,9 en tuer la
violence aveugle de 1982 à 1985
vingt-huit personnes décèdent sur les
tirs ni tueurs du brabant surnommé le
géant le vieux et le tueur par la presse
belge
les trois auteurs s'en prennent à des
supermarchés une armurerie ou encore des
auberges
à chaque fois le butin est dérisoire
face à ses actes la police s'avère
impuissante
l'enquète s'enlise pourtant les
hypothèses ne manquent pas après la
dernière attaque celle du 10 novembre
dernier à alost qui a fait huit morts et
13 blessés
un fait frappe les observateurs les
tueurs ont utilisé à la perfection des
méthodes rappelant celle des commandos
militaires parmi les hypothèses étudiées
les enquêteurs privilégient la piste
politique selon eux à la tête du groupe
il y aurait d'anciens gendarmes
d'extrême droite ce qui éveille leurs
soupçons c'est qu'à chaque fois les
dispositifs policiers sont des jouets
lors des braquages et en plus il manie
les armes comme des gendarmes
derrière ces actes certains y voient une
manoeuvre politique un mouvement
d'extrême droite qui aurait orchestré
les tueries du brabant pour déstabiliser
le gouvernement et conduira un
durcissement sécuritaire
finalement cette piste n'a jamais rien
donné
il faudra attendre près de trente ans
pour que la sphère connaissent à
rebondissements
en 2015 sur son lit de mort christian
bon qu'au ski un ancien gendarme aurait
livré à son frère un aveu surprenant
même beaucoup mon frère est
effectivement celui que l'on a surnommé
le géant c'est la vérité il me la note
il me l'a confié sur son lit de mort
aujourd'hui les tueurs du brabant n'ont
toujours pas été identifiées mais une
enquête est toujours en cours
la sphère sera prescrite en 2025
quarante ans après les derniers faits
[Musique]